quand on arrivait et que ma grand mère
disait mais c'est mathieu c'est ton
petit fils et dia oui ça va ça va et
l'école ça va et je répondais et 40
secondes après et l'école ça va et cinq
fois de suite jusqu'aux vouvoiement quoi
là quant à 14 ans que ton grand père il
te vous vois moi je me rappelle être
sorti de la pièce avoir pleuré c'était
voilà c'était difficile quand j'ai
appris pour l'alzheimer de mon grand
père je devais avoir peut-être 9 10 ans
et à ce moment là
je me rends pas compte que 2 des ravages
que peut faire l'alzheimer je me dis va
juste oublier certaines choses c'est et
puis en fait avec les années en
grandissant je vois qu'on lui enlève sa
voiture je vois que c'est pas juste des
mots qui est l'oubli où il a rangé ses
clés c'est commença à oublier
des personnes des prénoms ce qu'il a
fait il ya cinq minutes puis puis après
voilà ça s'empire et puis il ya aussi
des moments de démence il ya c'est dur
pour l'entourage
enfin c'est toutes ces choses là qui qui
évolue après au fil des années jusqu'au
jour où je suis arrivé que il m'a pas
reconnu ça c'est là j'ai compris qu'on
était qu'on attaque et une phase qui
allait être vraiment très difficile pour
nous l'entourage aussi et ce qui était
dingue c'est que ils me voyaient me
reconnaissez pas mais quand je lui
montrais les médailles ce qui était
militaire de carrière quand j'ai montré
ses médailles et que je les raconte
l'histoire de chaque médaille il te
raconter en détail
quand il était en indochine ses
blessures de guerre et est c est
racontée souvenait des ddd des souvenirs
comme salon atteint mais la mémoire
immédiate et tous étaient finis quand on
a beau être avoir traversé des guerres
être s'être relevé après des blessures
s'en est sorti est rentré auprès de sa
famille
et finalement c'est une petite saloperie
qui vient bousiller ton cerveau quoi on
n'est pas formé pour gérer quelqu'un qui
a des démences ou kiki qui dans les
premiers les premières phases de cette
maladie n'est pas prise en charge dans
un établissement les dernières années
de sa vie quand il a commencé à être
placée en centre mois gt gt sur les crs
étaient sur les routes donc j'étais
vraiment plus beaucoup auprès de ma
famille et je suis allé une seule fois
le voir au centre et je vais fin c'était
terrible le centre pour moi c'était de
le voir au milieu d'autres personnes
pareil qui sont qui retourne à l'état
d'enfant quoi de nourrissons ils sont là
à voir mon grand père comme ça sur un
fauteuil les yeux dans le vide avec la
bave
enfin c'est non ça je les fais une fois
et je suis j'ai dit je peux je suis
désolé mais je pourrais je pourrai plus
je peux plus le voir comme ça quoi
et puis quelques mois après il était
parti de clairement de le voir comme ça
je me suis dit mais laissez le partir
quoi c'était quelqu'un qui était
tellement dean tellement fier que il ya
aussi cette question là de se dire
est-ce que faut maintenir quelqu'un
coûte que coûte
moi je suis ce qui est qui qui sont
contre ce à quoi quand on dit
il ya 900 mille personnes atteintes de
la maladie en france faut multiplier le
chiffre par 6 7 10 en fonction des
personnes qui se retrouvent autour de la
personne atteinte donc donc ça fait
énormément de gens touchés en france et
sans se rend pas compte quoi de
commencer dur pour pour le compagnon la
compagne de la personne qui vit au
quotidien avec pour les enfants pour
pour les petits enfants il ya une
fatigue émotionnelle c'est ça prend ça
prend beaucoup d'énergie ça assez
beaucoup d'angoissé d'inquiétude
c'est à se réorganiser
réorganiser sa vie pour faire en sorte
que la personne soit jamais seul c'est
comme c'est comme surveiller un enfant
après déjà d'en parler c'est préparer
aussi les gens si jamais ça leur arrive
c'est de savoir à quoi on peut être
confrontés quant à nos proches est
touché par cette maladie donc pour s'y
préparer il faut savoir ce que ce que ce
qu'implique cette maladie dans quelques
années on le chiffre me passer de 900 à
plus de 2 millions de personnes
atteintes et
deux millions de personnes atteintes
veut dire peut-être 12 13 14 millions de
personnes concernées par cette maladie
donc ccc sensibiliser pour faire avancer
la recherche pour pour essayer de
trouver des moyens de se débarrasser de
deux ça ou de le ralentir encore plus ou
de pouvoir vivre avec sans vraiment que
ça aille jusqu'aux étapes de fin -
rendre les choses plus faciles et c'est
pour ça que je suis là et que j'ai voulu
prêter ma voix à la fondation que j'ai
voulu parler aussi de ce sujet là de
cette maladie là que ce soit dans mon
film où la fois que le film est passé et
continuer le combat quoi